tarot cards are extraordinary inventions
you can believe it or not one thing is
certain that the cards speak
[Music
] my name osvaldo menegazzi I paint the
drawing of playing cards in a
particular way but tarots that I am
interested in and I have known them
many years ago as  object of art and
from there this great passion of mine was born
an oran tarot is an ancient
playing card tarot cards are composed of 78
cards of which 22 are the cards
for divining point that was born towards the
fifteenth century among the most
interesting  and the most beautiful are the Milanese ones,
here probably the
most beautiful cards in the world have been produced
our cards are all handmade
so and work quite long and even
complicated each card has its own
meaning
each card says something then
placed next to it  on the other they
complete a speech
I always start from a card that is death
extraordinary card in the tarot that
from death there is rebirth life
u  n another interesting card the sun the
sun that gives life also the star for
example the age the eye point represents
the dreams that will come true
[Music]
are the houses to be taken in general
as fun
many times amusements that tell the
truth  and pay attention to
the cards on the extraordinary thing and I love
very much
[Music]